this is art breeder art breeder is a
place where there can be absolute
nightmares holy [ __ ]
oh my god okay
so art breeder is a website that allows
you to breed art
now in that vein it is easy to probably
get some misconceptions about what that
means and to be perfectly honest i don't
fully know it myself
when i say breed art what it's doing is
it's using some programming to merge
pieces of art together and this can
create lovely portraits
really lovely artly portraits like they
look like they're professionally drawn
but all these are just like mixtures of
different people i think you can just
like
oh what have i done what have i done
what have i done oh no oh no no
no no no no no
take it away
oh my god
so you can basically mix and match a
bunch of different
art and you can make different creations
and they can vary much like that website
of the google
was it google it was just ai built faces
much like that
chaos chaos
oh wait a minute the chaos
no chaos chaos no chaos
we're all just one slider away from
utter chaos
um but you can make a bunch of different
things besides horrible
people monsters you can also make
landscapes
beautiful landscapes this looks
fantastic like if you were someone that
was just looking for like some kind of
concept art for your
project you could probably come up with
some pretty innovative stuff although i
don't know what's going on there
chaos the chaos slider really turns it
to the surreal
i think it just starts to transcend
different dimensions oh
whoa whoa whoa zoom in
zoom zoom it just offers a lot of
different potential i don't know what is
going on with these
i don't know what's happening with these
just some kind of like dead space
monsters going on there
whoo wow this is totally uh
a sci-fi horror concept art here
horrible horrible horrible horrible
horrible
bring the cast back what
how oh no this i'm
i'm stepping no i'm stepping in places
where humans should not step what is it
saying to me what is it saying
what is it saying oh my god oh my god no
don't come closer
oh my god don't come any closer oh
no it was not that before it was
something completely different why is
that that new oh my god
so i'm having an existential crisis
wow
wait a minute okay maybe this ain't so
bad after all okay
okay let's bring the chaos back is it it
does the same thing
what is that what is that what is going
on there
i don't know oh i don't know i don't
want to know i don't want to know
oh no
oh my god okay so i haven't explained
anything and i haven't tried anything
out myself yet
but i hadn't really explored this before
i started recording this
and uh frankly i i wish i had because
maybe i wouldn't have
dove so deep into this rabbit hole this
dude look at this dude
where is dude look at this dude what
does he look like oh he's fine
and he's not fine and he's fine oh
[ __ ] what is chaos done to you
what is chaos done to you oh my god what
is
this is your brain on drugs
i can't believe that's the same person
that's crazy that's really oh
some horrible horrible resident evil
virus
oh oh grandma grandma no
grandma wow this video could just be
exploring other creations that other
people have made
and frankly it might be a lot of that
but i i do intend to
attempt to make some of this stuff
myself but wow i just wanted you guys to
get a good
good idea of um the kind of stuff that
it could make and some of this looks
like it could be done by
some really talented artists and that's
that's that's quite impressive
uh the rest of it looks like a nightmare
beyond anything i've ever seen
someone tried to build the ideal human
so this is enough looking there's plenty
of nightmare fuel out there so let's add
to the pile so there's a few categories
general portraits characters landscapes
sci-fi bio art
albums furries anime portraits so i'm
gonna go with general justice
you can animate these
oh okay let's see trending yeah what do
they got trending
oh no oh no okay this
at first i thought it was cute now i'm
starting to think it was creepy okay so
ah it needs to go from this to another
thing see i guess this maybe two seconds
linear
um and then to this sure let's go
play well that's just video is
processing you'll receive an email link
when it's ready all right so that's
cooking
when that comes in i'll i'll do it let's
just focus on making some like
uh
so let's do compose here
all right let's get some parents here
all right let's let's not do anything
that's already been made into something
can i just bring in art of my own or
does it have to always be derivatives of
other things
is that what it has to be oh no look at
this hooter
oh no oh no my soul
my soul oh no my soul
oh my soul
no no okay i'm guessing
they're not allowing you to upload
anything
i don't know why pricing i gotta pay for
this i gotta pay for the
advanced breeder champion breeder
oh uploads i have to pay to make
uploads ah [ __ ]
god is this worth it privacy what i
don't get private
oh man i guess i don't get
i'm paying for this [ __ ] apparently i'm
paying for it because i want to be able
to upload images to it because
i i don't want to use just the nightmare
that's already on there so i have to
you do not have to pay for this
obviously but you know i just want to
have the full experience
do i have it do i have the ability to
upload
hello they took my money and ran oh
there we go
oh hey cool start private mode oh is
that for like if you're making
making boobies how do i upload how do i
upload create
there has to be a way maybe i just click
and drag and do it where is
my there it is you nah
that didn't do it how do i upload how do
i upload how do i upload how do i blow
ah here we go create portraits or
landscapes upload okay
upload ah okay here we go okay upload
let's bring this dude in
hello uploads are approximations of the
original
they take up to an hour to process and
must contain a clear face
they're all private unless they take up
to an hour
what do you mean up to an hour what does
that mean get some more bandwidth
what am i paying for got a clear face
that's definitely a face
that's a face right there perhaps q
position 484
what other [ __ ] are uploading
pictures to this [ __ ] apparently the
website's popular all images get encoded
into a representation that the neural
networks can understand the image being
uploaded should generally resemble the
images the network already produces for
portraits it should be facing the camera
with the full face and focus and good
resolution on the face
man i should have read this beforehand
oh that's gonna
take so long i've only moved four
positions all right screw it we'll come
back to this in another episode if you
guys want to see me actually do this for
realsies
with my own stuff uh ask again later
i'll
give it a try god damn ai is terrifying
all right let's just make something it's
been too long we're going to just do
general i'm going to create a creation
method
we're going to just select some random
ass parents uh just some things that
speak to me
all right let's take random
what does all right we need two parents
i think it just started generating when
i went in there so let's get two parents
uh yeah you know what yep oh
jesus christ howler monkey was not the
right dna to put into this
timberwolf sure i don't want to save any
of those
hey i mean it's not good okay it's not
good this is not good
but let's take the howler monkey out of
there let's take the chaos down
see if we can get something going here
oh no oh i regret oh my god
oh no oh my god oh my god
oh my god okay all right um uh
oof of these i think this is the most
normal
what did i save it what what do you mean
what happened oh okay it saved it
oh oh my god oh my god okay um let's get
i don't want to do
that category anymore let's do portraits
i'm going to try to make a nice face
and that's going to be very nice this is
okay
the well some of them oh
look at this dude i love this dude this
dude and
oh yeah this lady okay let's see if what
we can get out of these
well seems like nothing's happening
i'll give it a minute while it's getting
a minute uh let's just look at some more
lovely works of art
the longer i stare at this website the
more itchy
i feel i feel like all the cognitive
abilities for me to understand what i'm
even looking at are breaking down is
trying to rapidly just figure
that's pretty good oh i like that
a lot that's super cool
i i really like that that's dope as hell
holy crap that was awesome that just
made that
seems like the website is lagging quite
a bit you know it seems to be running
slower
now that i paid for it it was running
fine before but now it's really starting
to slug along
i don't know what that's all about it's
kind of bs if you ask me so
i think that it needs to get its [ __ ]
together and get back to me because it's
kind of [ __ ]
i'm actually impressed by the furry art
like to be perfectly honest
that of all the pieces of art that i've
seen here some of these are
okay some are these it seems like the
furry art is actually pretty consistent
hello
and that too look at how good that looks
that if that was just posted on some art
website
i would never know you know some people
could probably just make instagram
accounts
that are entirely based out of
generating art god that's the scary
thing about the future right
when ai is able to generate works of art
that are
the same if not better than what humans
can do i mean what is that gonna mean
if ai gets to the point where it can
make youtube videos i'm gonna be in
trouble
i like this style though i mean there's
some things that are obviously going a
little weird with it but
in all honesty like it's got some
emotion to it let me just
i hope i don't break it oh weird that's
so crazy
it always goes back i don't know why it
always goes back to
that face i like this i like it a lot
but it's going so slow now what the hell
happened
come on it can't be that slow just
because of me
i paid money i paid real money
i put real ass real money
i put real money into it
you know oh yeah eyes open baby get the
eyes open
give me the eyes get the mouth open
i don't know why the skin's getting
darker
i have no idea why let's make a happy
face yeah then make an angry face oh
you know i liked it better before let's
go back but you know what this needs to
need 200 more hat
needs absolutely double the hat hat
this isn't nearly enough hat that's not
hat all right you know what screw it i'm
just gonna go look at different
categories let's start from left to
right okay we actually we've looked at
those i don't want to look at those
anymore those are creepy we've looked at
the faces this is
very impressive you have to admit this
is incredibly
impressive what it's definitely able to
do really well is human faces
even if they're slightly artistic these
aren't even really photo realistic faces
they definitely got like the cartoon
sliders pulled up on that i mean that
one's pretty realistic
like these are very accurate portrayals
of human faces and i think they are that
way because obviously people are like
putting them together and like making
them into different
shapes and faces i thought i saw it did
i not see
someone that i thought that looked like
vincent for a second
no but i mean damn like this is pretty
impressive that's pretty impressive
i like that okay and then you what
category is that
characters yeah characters okay yep okay
landscapes
got some good stuff here trending the
beautiful
look at that crap look at that garbage
god
oh man screw it it's so cool oh it's
beautiful
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] look at that sunset
oh my god oh [ __ ] hole in this guy
editor you uncomfortable in
[ __ ] that's beautiful it's incredible
that's a
that's astonishing that's stunning how
do they help you getting away with this
who's letting them get away with it oh
my god look at this
i don't even know what i'm looking at
but it's cool oh that's horrible
okay maybe it's not getting so fun it's
getting a lot less fun now the funnest
is going down the funness has dropped
considerably
album art
[Music]
i could see some artists just grabbing
one of these and popping it on because
this does seem
like album art weird so cool
then you got the furries look at that
them some furries
look at the some of this does look like
it could have been
professionally made that's fast and then
you've got that
uh but frick oh my god oh my god okay
it's like the farther down you go the
more
okay all right let's get out of here and
then you got the uh animes pretty
cool i'm i'm whoa i'm honestly kind of
stunned by all this
this is really something else i'm gonna
have nightmares
some of these are so horrific that i can
tell that they are just burning
themselves into my memory
and they will rise up when i least
suspect it and they will haunt my dreams
for the rest of my days
but for now i appreciate this and it is
a glimpse into what
ai and the potential of computing can do
for the creative space
it's terrifying in a lot of ways it's
very terrifying
it's super scary but also
it's really interesting what could
happen in the future
if you want to check this out for
yourself there's art reader uh
and if i ever do get this upload working
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna queue up
a bunch of uploads
if you guys want another video where i'm
actually making stuff of myself
i will spend a lot of time to make sure
that i wait out the cues and stuff like
that and i will try this with my own
pictures pictures of me
pictures of my friends pictures of other
youtubers i'll merge
them into horrible babies of each other
across burrito mall and it'll just be
some a terrifying amalgamation if you
want that leave a like and subscribe and
ring the bell to know when that's going
to happen
because if it does boy howdy will it
give you nightmares and you don't want
to miss out on those nightmares
because you it just makes life spicier
artbreeder.com
glimpse into the future in the future is
terrifying so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye the [ __ ] is that what is that
what is the penis tail
it's the headless horse with dicks for
limbs
okay bye
[Music]
you